I got polio in my right leg when I was
merely five I left my school due to it
but my mother was determined to put me
back in school and that's how I resumed
my education she believed that education
is extremely important and if it can be
made affordable for everyone then it can
change lives and that's what simply
learn and indic AI have done for me they
made the course of my choice affordable
it has helped me grow professionally
I live in Mumbai the City of Dreams with
my family I was extremely good at my
studies and I completed my bcom back in
2003 from Mumbai University soon after I
got a job as a lab assistant in fact I
did a lot of odd jobs before joining
WSI Alm Canada based digital marketing
agency as a link building executive in
2014 and I have been working there on a
work from home basis ever since last
year I upskilled myself with a post in
digital marketing
and after seven years of working at my
company I got promoted to the position
of SEO account executive with a 25
percent salary hike WSI LM is a good
company
I informed my manager about the
certification and I was given more
responsibilities at work I am very happy
with my career path
simply learns collaboration with indic
AI made this possible for me as I had to
only pay 5000 and the rest was paid for
it enabled me to take an expensive
course like this I never saw my
disability as an obstacle not even when
I was in school and my Hunger to learn
new things keeps on growing I like to
read self-help books in my free time I
enjoy listening to Bollywood music it
keeps me charged
in my journey my family has been very
supportive especially my brother
a big thanks to Simply learn and Indique
AI also I feel that many organizations
like these should continue to help
others and impact lives like the
impacted mind